Hey Youtubers it's Charlie. This is going to
be my Game of Thrones episode one video. I think
the biggest surprise was mostly things that we did not see, but it was a vast departure from the books
so I'll try to explain as we
go along in my top ten moments and
new round of the giveaway starts now. I'm giving away a signed copy of A Feast
For Crows and A Dance With Dragons. All you have to do to enter that is be a subscriber, and leave a
comment on this video. I'll have more details on that at the end of the video but
careful for spoilers if you haven't seen
the episode yet so here we go. Starting with top ten WTF moments.
Number ten. Cersei flashback. This is "Maggy The Frog" right out in the book. They did change
a few minor things but it's pretty honorable
to what happened in the book. Cersei learns
about Robert's bastards although she doesn't know it at the time. Twenty seems like a high number.
They killed a lot in King's Landing. Joffrey sent
the guards around to kill them all except
for Gendry who we know is still alive and supposedly there is a bastard in The Vale. Maybe more
than one. Remember he lived there during some of his younger teenage years with Ned
so he probably has a few bastard running around somewhere in The Eyrie. I love how young
Cersei is just as much a bitch as old Cersei. It's like some things just do not change.
When Maggy says "gold will be their crowns; gold will be their shrouds" she's talking
about burial shrouds too meaning they'll eventually
die; some sooner than others. You can take
this as a warning that Marcella and Tommen
are going to die but really it's so vague
that you can interpret it in a lot of different ways. It's
also kind of a sidestep into a different kind
of magic than we've seen on the show. We've
seen blood magic with Daenerys hatching the
dragons in season one. We see Melisandre's
magic from The Red God. We've seen white walker
magic which is slightly different, and we've seen the magic of the three-eyed raven.
All very distinct type of magic. I'm interested
to see if the show tries to tie some commonalities
between them by the finale. By like the series
finale. In all likelihood though George R.R. Martin is probably
leave a lot of this stuff figuring stuff
out to the reader. But on to number nine. Tyrion
makes it to Pentos. As expected he and Varys
end up at Illyrio's old house. We don't see Illyrio.
I guess the actors isn't on the show this
year. Varys kind of explains the Blackfyre
Griff storyline a little bit. He met Ilyrio
through a mutual friend that is part of a
group that wants to see a Targaryen restoration.
Because it seems like the show might be cutting
out a lot of the "Young Griff" storyline.
The Targaryen restoration group could be some
other big organization or it could be The
Golden Company. The Golden Company is
just one of the bigger mercenary group that
was founded by Blackfyres. Just add a bookmark
to Targaryen Restoration/"Young Griff" storyline
from the books. We can see how those things
matchup because they might give bits and pieces
to other characters. There was that teaser
that Nikolaj Coster-Waldau did with the duck
at the beginning the season, or before
the season started. As of this episode, I haven't
seen evidence of a Blackfyre pretender like
a "Young Griff" character but that doesn't mean,
that he's not somewhere in the season. I would
say Tyrion taking the drink of wine, throwing
up, then drinking more; probably one of the
funniest moment in the episode. Just a total boot and rally. On to number eight. Meet the
Sons of the Harpy. I just did a bonus video
explaining you know kind of in depth where
the group comes from; Where they originate
from; What the "harpy" name is all about so
I'll add a link for that in the description.
But generally this is the group being used
by the antagonistic slave masters that want
to kick Dany out so they can start slaving
again. This is really a TV style device where by they
use different costumes
to help you identify who is who.
So bright colors here equals Sons the Harpy
people. Everyone else is either a freed slave,
or a second son. They all have their distinct
clothing styles. Whenever there's like a big
battle and you get a little confused just
look bright colors vs. Unsullied. I tried
to figure what the tune the whore was humming
to him. It might been just something from
The Summer Isles like wherever he was from.
Like something that his mother may have hummed
to him before he was sold to slavers and
he became an Unsullied warrior. But it
was kind of funny that he was like "okay put
your pants back on; this is fine; we need
to do it this way". There's also this new
person on Daenerys' council. He's one of
the slaves that we met in season four. Someone from
the inside of Meereen who advocated supporting Daenerys' cause from the inside. So looks
like she's elevated him to her version of
The Small Council. On to number seven. Shit
is brewing up at the wall in the wake of the
battle with the Wildlings. So it hasn't been
that long and they're still trying to figure
out what to do with the Wildlings. Alliser
Thorne and Janos Slynt, if they had their way, would probably just
turn them loose to the mercy of the haunted forest
and the White Walkers, and whatever else would want to eat them out there.
Jon isn't in love with the Wildlings but
he doesn't want to turn them away if he doesn't
have to. He just wants to avoid more bloodshed.
The fact that he's spending so much time
with Olly here training Olly make me a little
bit worried. It's like the people with the brightest
faces usually have the biggest targets on
their backs. On onto number six, Stannis wants
Jon Snow to get the Wildlings to fight
for him. This is also right out of the books.
Stannis wants to make a deal with the Wildlings.
They're a big force; they're
great fighters. He's going to need them if
he's going to take Kings Landing. Taking
back Winterfell is a whole other thing. Yes
he does have enough people to take back Winterfell,
but because winter is coming they might get buried
in snow. Snow could cause a huge problem so
the more people they have the better, and
as of right now they are running short on
supplies so it's like there's almost no food
up at The Wall so things can't stay the way
they've been. The Wildlings either have to
take off or they have to go with Stannis. They
can't just sit around. The big holdup
is that Mance won't bend the knee. That's what
John has to do. He has to get him to bend
the knee. On to number five. Little Finger
and Sansa stashed the Sweet Robin in the
countryside of the Eyrie. The big takeaway here
is that they're just stashing him away so that he
can't cause any problems. Right now he is the
Lord of the Vale, so he is very dangerous just
for the sheer fact the he has so much power.
As we see in this scene though, he is a complete and
utter fool so no one is too worried about
him as long as he's off sitting in a corner
somewhere. If you look really hard you can
almost see Sansa's eyes rolling into the
back of her head as this all happens. On to
number four intro to The Sparrows. So in King's
Landing Cersei starts to eagle eye Marjorie.
We get like a teaser for the war that they're
going to start between each other. Also see
Lancel comes out of left field like he's been
brainwashed and says "I've been washed in
the light of The Seven". This is setting up
a really big book plot so if you know where
this goes just please use spoiler tags because
it's very important for this season. What you need
to remember though is that Cersei is making
her own plans to deal with Marjorie, Marjorie
with Cersei so they had this thing going on and then there's the church in the background. So those
three forces are going to be affecting each
other in really really big ways. Lancel is
just like our introduction to The Sparrows
until we meet The High Sparrow. On to number
three. Hizdahr compels Daenerys to reopen the
fighting pits in Meereen. Remember Hizdahr
is like the representative of all the slaving
families, He's a member of one of the slaving
families. Even though he seems fairly
harmless, I think that he's gonna turn out to be
the Harpy. The one controlling
the Sons of the Harpy. But they do call back to
the Wise Masters of Yunkai. So they've been back, like the Wise Masters took power
whenever Daenerys left. They took back power.
So now she's trying to set up more of a Republic
situation where you have a group of people
ruling the city. We'll see if that lasts.
I'm gonna go ahead and bet on no. I did like Daario's
backstory like he narrates his backstory. My mother sold me
into slavery, but hey you know a turned in
a great fighter and it help me survive. it
makes me a little weary of Daario but
so far he hasn't given me a reason to think
that he's gonna betray Daenerys in a big way.
Not as much as I think that Hizdhar will. On to number two.
Varys explains to Tyrion why he wants
Daenerys on The Iron Throne. It's always interesting
to find out you know what the characters,
like the Westeros characters, think of Daenerys.
We as the audience are privileged in that we get to spend a lot of time with Daenerys but
Tyrion only knows of Daenerys what he's been told,
and as he said he was drunk during most those
small council meeting so he barely remembers. Someone stronger than Tommen but softer than
Stannis. Although Stannis does seem like he has a heart like whenever he has scenes
with his daughter Shireen he seems fairly loving. Loving in like in an icy cold "Stannis"
kind of way. I think what Varys is implying is that he wants Tyrion to go be on Daenerys'
Small Council. More than anything he's a gifted politician so he can help Daenerys with her people
problem. Daenerys can raise soldiers that's not
her problem. It's dealing with citizens
that's her problem. And finally my number one WTF moment Mance Rayder burned at the stake.
This is also right out of the books. He gets burned at the stake but it seems like they
departed from the books. I don't give away too many spoilers because it is at the end
of book five and most people haven't read that. Melisandre uses a little bit her glamour
magic and there's a bit of
a twist in the plot. I'm assuming that they
just cut that out. So unless we see otherwise in a future episode just assume that Mance
is dead. The books stuff spills over into
Rattleshirt and it seems like Rattleshirt
was in the trailer so, whenever we see him
in like a future episode, I'll explain
that a little bit more. But the big takeaway
is that they kill Mance so they're gonna
try and treat with the Lord of bones. He's
like the new leader the Wildlings so hopefully
he and John can come to an arrangement. Here's
my big question for you guys though
what was your favorite moment from the episode, and you know once Tyrion eventually makes
it to Daenerys what do you think that he's going to be helping her with specifically
like what is she going to ask him to do?
I think it would really just be the same stuff
he did when he was Hand of the King in season two. Mostly like tedious administrative stuff
managing managers so that everything in the city
just ran smoothly. He's also a really good
battle planner too. So I'd be interested to see
you know who is better at making war. Tyrion
or Daario. Daario is a better fighter and he does
lead the Second Sons but that doesn't
make him a genius war master. The army that Daenerys has is vastly greater in size than
the second son's, Daario is more like a spec ops guy. When you need to infiltrate somewhere
or some covert op that's the person
you send in. Some of my other favorite moments though
were like the creepy looks that characters were giving each other. Like I mean you know
there was a nice creepy moment with Jamie and Cersei above Tywin's body. Not quite
the same as the last time they were standing over a dead body, I didn't say a lot about
Tywin's funeral. There is a small change from the books. He farts a lot like it's really
stinky and it ends up being this really funny thing
because he's such a powerful person and everyone
hates him, Pod and Breinne were a lot of fun too mostly I'm just happy that she's
not dead. Melisandre looking a Jon Snow too though oh man. She was looking at him like
he was like a piece a cake or something like
she was just gonna eat him and Daenerys
visiting Viserion and Rhaegal. Yeah I'm just waiting for
them to go ape shit. Just a reminder my Q&A
for this is going to post tomorrow, and I
will announce the winners of my book giveaway
the signed books. My next
bonus video will post next Sunday.
If you have any requests for that just leave
them in the comments I might do, like House
of Black and White or something like that.
If anyone wants to help me out with subtitles
you can actually submit fan subs for any of
my videos so if you just want to do like Game
of Thrones videos that'd be amazing. That would
be like a huge help to me. If someone does
it on a regular basis there also might be
like an extra gift card in there for them too.
So in case you guys haven't seen it yet
you can click here to learn more about the
history of the Sons of the Harpy and Meereen and
you can click here for the Q&A video.
I'll update the annotation as soon as I
post that video tomorrow. Thank you so
much watching this is going to be such an awesome season
everybody let's high five and I'll see you tomorrow.